cette génération là elles ne valent en
vente elle crée elle propose l mn
partage je pense que ma génération est
clairement multiples elle et elle les
riches surtout parce qu'elle est pleine
de différents horizons de différentes
cultures de différents genres des
différents goûts différentes origines de
différentes langues de différentes désir
de différentes de différents savoir
faire c'est une génération qui peut être
est taxé de 2,2 d'être amorphe d'être
sur les réseaux en permanence et tout ça
sauf que justement c'est une force
j'en suis convaincu étant donné que
c'est une matière qui nous permet de
savoir et d'être au courant c'est à dire
que même si on ne veut pas de toute
façon on sait ce qui se passe dans le
monde je pense que c'est une grande
force et c'est l'une des raisons
d'ailleurs pour lesquels les réseaux
sociaux sont interdits dans certains
pays parce que c'est la voix du peuple
et que c'est la manière dont le peuple
veut s'unir c'est l'une des voix
l'inde est l'un des vecteurs l'un des
outils cas le peuple pour s'unir et pour
parler d'une seule et même voix pour
signer des pétitions pour dire là on
n'est plus d'accord c'est un autre moyen
qu'on a deux exprimé de prendre la
parole et grâce à ça justement cette
génération-là l9 alan van elk réel
propose l mn partage elle chérit elle
est en colère elle s'exprime
et ça je pense que ça n'a pas de prix et
que c'est justement une génération qui
est beaucoup plus en action que ce qu'on
croit